citizens of the reject Nation we are back to
be invaded with episode 4 today John how's it
going I am uh shape-shifting into all forms of
excitement it's getting better jokoy how are you
I hope the invasion Isn't So secret so people
start watching the show nice I like to hear it
ladies and Gentlemen please go ahead and invade
that like button also if you are planning on going
to Comic-Con real rejects us three are going to
be having a panel Saturday July 22nd one o'clock
P.M Link in the description box for more details
can't wait to see what more of that Fury goodness
is up to that dog with his bird's eye view what
am I everyone leave the video my feathered rejects
today I've got a tail waggingly good Scoop for
you let's talk about our sponsor bird dogs I'm
wearing them comfortable pants right now but
also they have their shorts that'll have you
looking fetching these shorts are no bird brainers
my friends let me show you they're designed to fit
Slimmer through the thigh and the leg giving you
a truly possum sculpted look they do everything
Lululemon does but with an extra wag in their tail
so say goodbye to those rough cotton shorts bird
dogs fix that Mudder by creating their Cloud knit
fabric I mean come on it looks as sharp as khaki
but stretches like a dog chasing its tail you're
just gonna waste them or fit without being you
know leash stricted got these puns going people
here's the cherry on top or should I say the
bird on the wire when you order from bird dogs.com
using my special code rejects you'll fetch a free
Yeti style tumbler it's the perfect companion for
hydrating on your adventures ah Grandpa's medicine
so don't sit on the perch my pals hurry over to
birddogs.com rejects to unleash the possum power
of these shorts and snag your free Yeti style
tumblers trust me once you experience the comfort
and style you'll be barking about bird dogs to
all your buddies they really are comfortable and
a lot of people want to know what are some of the
best ways to support the channel one of the best
ways to get yourself some bird dogs by getting
your tail wagon head to birddogs.com rejects now
[Music] ourselves that's extremists
I don't know if any of the comments
pointed it out last episode I thought it
was just common knowledge among us all
away she's gonna set up right now
charity super it's like there's no way
they're killing him regenerative power
there it is that's extremist people
everybody knows Iron Man 3. Holdridge Killian
what's funny is I didn't put together his
hand healing and her just doing the same thing
[Music]
who would have thought that she's still
alive the thing that happened earlier in
the episode might also apply to her skills
I love when they just take that big piece
of stakes and just immediately
solve it as the opening button
it's a lot of filling in the gaps in
this show they do a good job jumping
around the timeline but not timelines as
I was watching all the news coverage of
those guys strangest thing someone I know had
something to do with getting them all together
and what if it was someone you
know half of his face is de-aged
that looks so good he understands that
the weaker worth goddamn right good book
actually it's a conversation between two
people that will very much reflect our own
and did you get what you wanted from this life
even so I did it's gonna be a heartbreaking finale
yeah to call myself beloved to feel myself
beloved on the earth she really loves him oh
talk about give us some Romance
I'm gonna plow your ass
so you the Poetry of love making
that's where I learned Ezekiel 24 14 or whatever
you said that book got another good book I got
a poem for you I fired Fury okay nope sorry
correction I ddt'd that dude from the top rope
yeah it was like Undertaker level you just sprayed
him with pesticide this girl's big wrestling fans
my graphic needs what graphic doesn't need that's
none of your concern I'm the one telling you to
kill Fury oh what damn it scrotie look I'll make
it easy for you one of the two occupants of that
lovely country manner of yours is catching
a bullet today jeez flip coin for all I care
wow from exhaustion and defeat soon enough
we don't need to kill him man this is sad
you keep telling me what you're not gonna
do I'm gonna show you what I am going to
ooh now you enjoy this concert
if we consider it it's just Roadie this is
who he's been all this time real son [__]
I don't need your sorrow or your pity
for anything I did of my own free will
what is your plan for finding our people at home
because graphic has already implemented his and
it works got a napkin in a pen we take down the
Insurgency we go to the present and we have a big
bargaining chip just saved your planet now give
me a little something in return I can secure an
amnesty for the one million of us to remain
jeez I don't know don't you want to live in
your own skin it's very optimistic we just keep
contributing show them our hearts they will see us
generational debate in the capsule you were
delusional and that is not who I've become
they're gonna go right back
to graphic that's really
short-lived didn't think you'd be home until later
surprise T sure I'll take a cup surprise [__]
of all the Reckless things I've done in my life
away greatest mistake oh shh ignored every
signal in my head heart and body that screams
stop I don't know that if I had a chance to do
it over again then I'd do anything different
oh
like laying all the cards out would you tell me
the story it's going to Tarantino movie chills
her Dr Priscilla Davis had his congenital
heart defect she was keeping it a secret
looking for someone who would slip your defenses
ah so you playing the long game on me even then
don't do that Nick she gets to call him
Nick I decided to just come out and ask
I asked if she wanted to fall
in love and I told her about you
interesting make her three promises very
hurt see which I did honorable that I
would continue to be a daughter
to her parents you've also done
that I would never hurt you
oh and did you get what you wanted from this
life even so what's about to happen I did I think
they're gonna kill her and it's gonna be hard
what did you want to call myself beloved ah yep
to feel myself Beloved the Earth whoa God damn
really did become a Tarantino movie
decoding the Superhuman Gene was her book
I'm not sure if this means we should get divorced
beautiful that was really well done would
you have loved me if I'd never changed
if I'd been my true self
oh guess we'll never know
Secret Wars the wars of the heart
oh they're just like us
all my fetishes are coming through on Disney Plus
shape of water just wasn't enough
oh my God my fetishes are ruined oh
they call them War Machine show
you where the only thing Roadie
has been a scroll memory serves I [__]
canned you into Oblivion a few days ago
I didn't like the way we left things between
us I wanted to share my favorite liquid lunch
with you Papi Van Winkle 23 years of distilled
Perfection I figured we could settle our beef
like you know proper gentleman like Harry
has like a really sincere conversation with
his wife and then you see the personas yeah
yeah presentational the interrogation tactic
if you waste one drop of this family reserve
your ancestors will reach out from the Beyond
and strangle your black ass let's drink his for
him really a black ass he's a green ass broken
tell you there are Scrolls
inside the U.S government
Scrolls in my security details Scrolls in the US
government that just because
I have an excellent Authority
that there is a scroll mode very close wow very
close close to you and I are right now all you got
to do keep my mouth shut about all this give
me my job back you mind if I make a counter
shouldn't have had that drink
man you see this all right
whoa that's graphic that's not me that's a a six
foot tall bald black one-eyed extraterrestrial
foot tall one-eyed black extra
restroom my power to protect you
to keep this video and you know all
the copies that I made Under Wraps
is that audio wave yeah I was curious
it's moving still liquid location tracker
it's not a bad idea hey clever
assuming the president bites it soon sir
Harrison Ford takes over oh hey spoilers
you have to project strength uh there's an old
linen quote Vladimir not John when you find flesh
you push when you find steel you stop Colonel
can I ask you something absolutely anything sir
pre-game for our bilateral with the
Russians or the half a bottle of bourbon
I'm not sure I understand the questions sir
interesting president's got to be a drunk
to pick up on that even though the type
oh my God
damn
no
[__] Harrison Ford's going to come
running into frame in a second any moment
be graphic to death with ritson's body
shot yeah
this roady's not going there
good shots good shots
Chinese
it's the Russians look at
them they're clearly right
damn woof
nice this looks great yeah no
it's great sexual directed action
oh planner to be a Killzone
if we don't save written huh
you got your pistol
oh there we go there we go
nicely done
yeah
helicopter that was sick
we're playing hot potato with the president
cool
nervous damn I am graphic
how many powers does he have
I wish they would all prioritize
a resting Fury stop get this man
he's gonna let him be the
one to save the president
is everyone watching on the scroll I'm
punching this bulletproof glass I'm
gonna transform right as I pull him out we are
your friends oh no no no no not not my Talos
oh [__] damn they're about fine ass girls are
come on man let's go oh he's like
sacrificing himself on the way out
oh no
[Music] he's with me he's with us hey damn okay
where's Gaia so she can see this
damn that's a good makeup yeah CGI
combination hang in there I'll be back for you
oh don't just leave him have someone else take
the president put it in my car I got my own right
guy sympathetic for reals
trust this I don't like it
oh [__] no I said put him down now no no
no no no no no no no no no whoa damn it so
oh you gotta be shitty damn
[Music]
oh you gotta be kidding me
come on we can save him oh
save him come on grab him
let's drive over there
all right
why why what do you mean who's in that shoes yeah
oh golly don't worry guys next episode it's gonna
be night time in Towson just
gonna wake up what happened
well the only body on this freeway
all right let's talk about holy [__] damn yeah
that was a lot I was hoping in the trailer when
they showed his face all messed up that that was
just gonna be a fake out but damn looks like they
really really got it there all right well let's
uh let's play some bets now let's play some bets
I think Talos will not be back for five but I
think somehow through the power of super scrolling
Shenanigans they might be able to bring him back
for episode I think in the final episode we'll
come back I feel like they're gonna make us think
he's dead for a whole one a whole yeah yeah yeah
let's adjust it Jesus koi how many times there it
is uh do you think he's dead dead I'm gonna double
down like I did with Amelia Clarke I love you Ben
Mendelson but you did I feel like he's going or or
he's actually going they will bring him back but
he's going to let everyone think he's still dead
that way his dad Warren Samaritan yeah exactly
yeah yeah I'm going that's where I'm going with
my theory on that sure but um if he actually
is dead that's a really solid sacrifice and
it went down that whole path saving the president
in public if given up your identity doing it like
the very thing you said to your daughter you do
being a man of your word now we know though that
Harrison Ford is going to be they've already
confirmed it that he will be president in Captain
America new world order do you think he might undo
whatever happens here for the Scrolls maybe Dermot
Mulroney is able to do oh who knows if Dormont
even makes it what if the sacrifice was in vain
care about what happened in this episode now I'm
only thinking about the future seven movies yeah
either president is gonna you know try and do
some scroll-based uh you know policy pumping
is there an ending you can explain or Easter
eggs you can point out or or maybe did he know
maybe he'll just get uh his term and we'll just
end yeah the new president by way of Elections
yeah oh man that was a heavy episode man I'm
like wiped yeah that was really emotional I
was very invested in the emotionality
of the first half and then the action
of the second half and then all of a
sudden there was an emotional action
there was there was I thought the the action was
well done it was beautifully there's not a lot of
action in this show and so when it was happening
I was like all right this is good this is like
actually Ali slam got to Showcase some of his
you know action prowess and I love a good that
I feel like that's the new thing now has a lot of
good mounted locked off shots nice mounted uh POV
angles other items in motion yeah I really like
the way I looked though I also really like that
they set up to have it like off to the side so
they could really get good coverage of the fight
like they had the presidential you know cavalcade
go over here and then you could really shoot the
fight and do real practical explosions like
some of that was CJ but they actually blew
some stuff up they did oh Easter egg Easter egg
keyword thank God for getting this out of the way
grew tanned root hand yeah yep he's got Groot
abilities that he just like selfishly take them
all on or did he like evenly distribute this
amongst all the other you know intercourages
part of me does Wonder here's my theory
to get that uh that click word uh I think
that he will have taken so many treatments of
the super scroll juice whatever it is that he
will gain all these Powers but they will be too
much for his body to yeah I am the Mandarin yes
exactly I think he explodes like the end
of blade or he just pumps all that blood
of things oh man uh I I really was impressed with
everyone's acting this considering they had to do
a lot in 30 some minutes in this episode and like
that means every scene had to be like that was a
really good fake out with the whole thing with the
wife oh man the Cutaway they shut the house yeah
yeah because it seemed like they were said I was
thinking okay it's going to be like heartbreaking
by the by the end of the series right and then
if they killed her off if they if it killed off
part of me was gonna be like man this is really
sad the other part of me was I wish we got to
spend a little bit more time getting invested in
their you know actual relationship and then they
did both this episode because they were kind of
blue valentining it you know where they would cut
to like they're in love in the flashback it's
gone horribly it's horrible and depressing you
know uh and they're singing with a banjo Let
It Ride Gosling rest yeah yes uh but oh dude
someone put I think on one of our live streams
they pointed out that the person who plays his
wife is actually the one who plays this is small
the places is Samuel Jackson's mom from the glass
definitely expanded
I was like it's his mom what
is happening John it's not
but the emotion that she brings uh because you
could feel that conflict that she's having the
whole time because I wasn't as exactly 100 on
board because they they didn't confirm what
her plan was in the last episode or what she
was being instructed to do right by Roadie to
kill Nick I was like wow that's a reveal that
you're just dropping on me at the beginning of
this episode and then when she's having that
confrontation at the table that had so much
sorrow and I loved I loved the way how uh Samuel
Jackson played that whole moment too because uh
like we pointed out he was so like dejected
and it was another one of those speeches of
like yeah you know this was like a big mistake
but I also don't regret any of it yeah so the
way they did lead up to them ultimately pulling
the trigger on each other and the way they've
reacted to after the triggers were pulled that's
the relationship yeah yeah that's the good Blue
Valentine like they're back in the happy for this
moment and it's because they can laugh about that
and accept these kind of weird idiosyncrasies
about each other and stuff strange perspectives
about life like this is just a weird lifestyle we
live you know what you think about our backstory
John what do you think about Priscilla's backstory
I thought that was very interesting and touching
good abductions out there yeah no it seemed like
a really beautiful and I liked I I love when you
get a story told in monologue that never breaks
from just the actor delivering the monologue and
you can see it in your head and uh and I thought
that was an example this this was I thought like
an overall really strong episode and especially
for things like that and I thought that yeah
what her story was because you sit here and
wonder you're like yeah they have to take on
people's personae and these are good skulls how
do they do that and I really like the idea of
like please live my life like I love the idea of
her saying like do you want to fall in love like
that's so painful sure like do you want this
Visage to know love because you're dying Imma
Be You Like that's just so heavy yeah absolutely
beautiful monologue and it's like yeah it's like
it it is a little odd and twisted but in a way
that ultimately turns out quite beautiful and I
think that that showing her true compassion giving
like a kind of nice window into who she actually
is because between her and Nick like there's a lot
of these Espionage games and stuff um but yeah I
thought that was wonderfully humanizing and that
combined with how that scene ultimately played out
yeah made that a perfect moment whereas again if
I if if she was about to die I feel like I would
have kind of felt undercut yeah yeah exactly yeah
and now to uh no smooth transition here but with
Roadie yes Don Cheadle really gets to Showcase
his acting caliber here because the the you have
the one scene with him in episode two uh where
he fires Nick right and now that it's revealed
that uh he was a scroll by the way he makes a
hot ass girl I mean you were getting the shower
[Music]
[Laughter]
let me find my words um oh yes
normally when you when they do
like are we a villain reveal and then
this actor shows up he's like hang on
now I'm now I'm playing into the fact that
I'm really a scroll right it didn't do that
it still felt like the same performance carrying
over from episode two and in episode two it was
only supposed to semi make you question episode
two wasn't enough to make me go he's definitely
a scroll right you know it's enough to still
make me go that could still just be Roadie's
principles speaking here and and roady's mentality
and perspective on the whole situation speaking
on this matter where's Nick right no it makes
really solid writing and I like how this still
feels like the same performance there even
though now they've let the audience know
that he is a scroll and he only like I love the
cat and mouse game of that conversation because
you know Nick's obviously taunting him so much
and he start you could tell in Don cheadle's
um performance the way he's reacting to him that
does Nick know him actually yeah you know how much
is debating me or is this just being him being
him yeah I I really enjoy that we don't know
you asked her in the episode like when he took
over I really love that like we don't know yet
like I love that there's a mystery but there's
still more mystery like we've solved some of it
and we don't know and it's I'm really curious that
they've like picked someone that has been recast
you know it's it's interesting that Terrence
Howard's one of the only Marvel characters
that's like a new face and he's a skrull and
he's got a movie coming out so there's a lot
might have been Avengers end game that's my
prediction he wanted to kill Hitler and he
went back Hitler was a scroll that would explain a
lot yeah baby Thanos that's what it was skriller I
mean Deadpool went back to go kill little baby
Hitler and then he's got a movie coming out so
maybe don't matter maybe yeah coming soon
Taco it he's gonna play babies [Laughter]
take away these Google Hitler this is
called Joe rabbit it's a prequel oh God
uh it's late extremist group Powers oh guy is
back yay all right congratulations hey you're
gonna get some true meat to that performance
and then but then they kill her dad you get
like five seconds on the bench with her and
they're like man it's like they cast Emilia
Clark and whenever I feel like we're we're
finally about to get some real mealia Clark
scenes come on come on we just don't get
eyes are so big and full of depth let us
do something well like I want to like live
with her for a bit well that's what I think
um you know uh that that's why Talus being fridged
you know am I use I'm using the term properly only
a woman can be fridge no no yeah yeah Telus is
fridge yeah it serves the purpose yeah Nick Fury
and then now we'll get some time with Gaia as as
she's you know that graphic guy is such an [__]
such a dick such a dick and now he's got powers
so a lot of this at the beginning of this episode
uh you know did speak towards uh Nick Fury's
righteousness side but also you know part of his
stubborn qualities do you think he made the right
decision in just leaving Talos at the end John
you go first you take the decision I think you
may have to be careful you're white because come
come across gracious you should have absolutely
just run directly to tell us the side and firemen
lifted him and then pulled the car by hand off the
freeway uh correct answer I think he made the the
decision for the Optics as you would say of the
situation he made the decision that he had to make
uh if it was me out of trying to go back for Telos
but he's kind of freaking saved the president like
I don't know too many things could go wrong so I
get why it happened personally I uh I feel like
he is you know in and out of government favor
and also been on the run and kind of a fugitive
and half the government might be his girls because
Roadie is saving their president's a good step in
the chess game but their friendship was so strong
and they'd known each other so many years I wish
he could have tried I would have tried well that's
where my the knits of my pick come in because Nick
Fury my friends don't call me Nick they call me
don't worry about it a thousand little details
get anything done he is so Fury
half of these proposition files are just
minutia man come up with a plan uh no this
was an episode that for all of us we have
struck the right tone for this episode
the knits of my picks for this episode this was
one of those ones where like all the great things
about it kind of brought into relief what I'm
worried about which is during this one I was
like man if this was like an Andor 12 episodes
or something like we could really cook some of
this stuff and I feel like especially with some
aspects of the emotional story because we only
really have big visual on the scroll conflict
in Captain Marvel so this even though it's all
running alongside the universe and the MCU and
they're they're hopping around in different
movies you know timelines and whatnot it still
feels like this story has really kind of only
been happening through Captain Marvel to this so
it feels still kind of contained to me and I you
know it's supposed to be like damn this big steak
is affecting like everything we know about how the
world works right now okay I agree because I think
that a lot of the scenes when it's just like scene
work the best thing the show has gone for it is
like when they just have like two actors talking
to each other love it they're just great scenes
and then you kind of feel like but the overall
story would just feel that much more exponential
if they had more of a run time with these last
couple episodes too put a little bit more juice in
there so that one's left and then it's starting to
feel like oh it's not exactly rushed but a little
too short yeah like somewhere there well I'm a
little worried about how it wraps up because the
first two episodes were so long and then the next
one last one was like it was a little shorter
than the last house and this did a kind of two
sides of the coin for me because during the scene
with Priscilla I was like okay they might lose me
oh no wait this is the perfect choice for what
we've gotten to experience for this show and
then with talo so Talos whatever I I was sitting
there going man I would feel this a lot harder if
we had really like I love one more man I love
their relationship I love a lot of that stuff
but there's not quite enough in that Foundation
to make me like choke up or something like that
when they threaten us with this because they also
had him in a lot of other episodes get his like oh
awesome moment in this episode he like sat in the
bench and like the way he saved was great but like
he had that underwhelming big plan and I was like
okay now he's dead you're a big player so I would
have loved one more Scene could have had a better
build up to that moment yeah like overall through
it it's still like again it's like isolated scenes
but if there was like other thing other scenes in
between to just add on to it then it's called
what's called fleshing it out right um but yeah
uh overall I still love the show I still think
there's some of the best scene work in all the
MCU it's like right here yeah uh so yeah surprises
yeah man I still really like the episode let's see
if uh Disney plus can uh stick the landing and I
can't wait to see all the actors promote this come
the finale um yeah buddy you know when tomorrow
goes well and everything goes back to normal it's
coming tomorrow what's happening all right guys
well leave your nitpicks down below knit Fury
yeah and it's Fury cadent Nick Fury yeah leave it
down below uh subscribe thank you to bird dogs for
um you know not dogging on my my legs
and uh playing Guy Gardner cool and um
of the day shout out
Michael B on the media no it's just Michael
B I actually know his last name I should by
this point I know it oh it's right
there no it's not is this last name
Michael B movie Omni media is his YouTube channel
I like this guy here's the thing is we're shooting
this midnight and uh shooting and editing you know
we're doing our thing he is three hours ahead and
he is doing the exact same thing so he's starting
as a 3am so loser suffer sucker your Sleepless
Sunrise is coming inside that that shows his hard
work and dedication so if you haven't checked out
his YouTube Channel please go ahead and do that
show him some love let him know real rejects sent
you especially if you're coming to this portion
of the video this is late it was like an hour
before in our video uh that means you're a loyal
follower so please go ahead show him some support
because he absolutely deserves it he's even done
some reactions here with me so guys thank you
Omni for being here and uh thank you all for being
here I'll talk to you all soon ASAP reject Nation